走り走っていくっていう
それを拝見してちょっと思い出したんですけど
娘が、ミスターが彼女の主人なんですけど
私の娘の
娘はバグバグ公園で
今の女性だと
動きの形状に
整形状とか
やってます
やっぱりやすいです
知ってます
すごい厳しい形で
僕が学生の時
いつも山谷先生が形状やって
子供たちが乗ってました
面白いやってました
もう
3000年くらい前かな
力ちゃんの年齢から考えると
私は
僕はよくバチコエってた頃です
本当にそう
たくさん持ってました
バタイマバとかでよく
ええ、もうしょっちゅう
山谷先生
大人に来てくれた
なんかもうだいぶお年なんで
そうですね
最近は
最近はなんか
返事が来なかったから
大丈夫かなと思ってたんだ
そう
山谷先生の息子さんに会いました
去年
ジュイさん
はい
私も知ってる
奥様も
そうですか
それはびっくりですよ
ところ
もう本当に
40年近く前になった
いろんな方の女の子が
増えてしまったんだけど
撮影してしまったんだけど、あの…
エイゾーはなんて言うか、話の時は、すごいんでしょ?
ちょっと、40年前です.
いぐらい前にね。
僕の知ってる人だと、新城さんってあるわけだろ。
新城さんはね、知ってます。
本当ですか、新城?
あれ?あれ?
どうですか?
新城さんはもう、世話になりました。
大学の時のコーチだから、全て教えて頂いて。
あー、そうですか。
新城さんがやってたのが、馬術の授業で、それを今、僕が教えてます。
はい、いいですね。
私はあんまり、あの、特に協議会に出ようとか、そういうのが目的ではなかったもんで、
結局、あの、第三科目までしかできなくて。
やっぱり、こっちの第三科目。
まあ、第三科目では出たことあるんですけど、でも、そんな…
ご視聴ありがとうございました。